so good afternoon everybody and um thank
you for coming this afternoon it's
lovely to see some faces looking back at
me doing a talk i've been doing virtual
talks for a year or more now i'm getting
really sick of the site of my webcam
so so yeah it's nice to see some people
this afternoon i'm going to be talking
to you about two frameworks that i
really enjoy using a lot
one of them is blazer
i've been doing a lot of work with
blazer
and
the other is tailwind css okay
i've been actually using both of these
at my company we've been we're using
this to build our production system um
so so yeah they're really great
technologies
and i want to share
how you can use them together with you
today
uh before i get into everything i'll
just quickly introduce myself so i'm
chris
i'm a principal software developer for
deployed
we're a start-up based in the uk
and yeah great group people really enjoy
working there uh i'm also a microsoft
mvp
i do a bit of blogging
at my blog although that's been a little
bit quiet for the last year or so
because i've been
busy writing a book
which is called blazer in action for
manning um
it's true what they tell you uh writing
a book is is really hard uh there's
quite literal my blood sweat and tears
involved in that mainly tears i'll be
honest but that's now done all the
chapters are finished and that's going
to be hopefully available in print at
the the start of next year which is
great
um as well if just you know in case i
have any other spare time i also do some
open source work so i have some packages
under the name blazered and they offer
various uh things to do with blazer so
we've got some things like uh interop
libraries for local storage or just
general ui components like modals and
toasts and stuff like that
anyway that's enough about me uh let's
get into things
so um
i'm going to start off with with all the
basics here so we're going to start off
by
answering this question of what is
tailwind css
uh
well simply put tailwind css is a
utility-based css framework
and what this really means is that with
tailwind we apply atomic style classes
so these are very small very focused
classes usually revolving around a
single
css property
and what we do is we compile those
together and we compose them to create
the look that we want
one of the really big uh sort of selling
points i feel for tailwind css is that
you pretty much never have to actually
write any css
okay
and that is a very interesting thing i'm
going to be doing about 40 minutes or so
of code demos in this talk and i will
make a promise to you now that you're
not going to see me write out a single
css property in order to do it
the other thing about tailwind css is it
makes it very very quick to actually
build uis okay because you're not having
to jump between files going creating css
over here and then html structure and
markup over there
it's very quick to develop you can build
your eyes very rapidly
so let's have a look at what this looks
like in practice
what i've got here is a slide that shows
the card component from a popular
framework that we probably all know
called bootstrap okay
and this is a pretty common thing with
something like bootstrap bootstrap is
like a ui component library
so what you tend to do is you put
pre-built ui components into your app
and you do that by copying this set
markup with these set css classes and
you get the the look that you that you
see there on the left hand side of the
slide
so if we were going to do something like
this in tailwind there's not these kind
of pre-made classes we would build this
ourselves using these utility classes so
let's have a look what that looks like
so in this slide i'm keeping the mark up
the same the actual html elements but
the classes are different
so if we just have a quick walk through
those hopefully these will start to make
sense relatively quickly
so on that outer div
i'm specifying that i want to use effect
i want to use flexbox i want to use
display flex and i'm doing that by
adding the flex class
i'm saying i want the flex direction to
be column by adding flex col
and this means that all of the child
elements are get stacked vertically
if you have a have a look at that card
component there you can see there's a
shadow and i'm
i'm adding that by calling the shadow or
adding the shadow large class
and then on the image it's got slightly
rounded top corners so i get that by
doing rounded t i can also just do i can
do a rounded top right corner around it
top left or whatever i want to do
that h40 defines the height of the image
now 40 itself doesn't actually represent
a number that doesn't directly mean 40
pixels or 40 rem or m's or whatever you
happen to choose that actually maps to a
number in a design system and that's
configured separately and this is
another very powerful feature of
tailwind we'll talk more about that in a
second
that inner div has got a padding of four
around it that's what p4 is and again
that maps to a number in the design
system
tex grey 800 that refers to the colour
palette that's built into tauwin towing
comes with a a good set of colors
pre-built into it
and i'm just referencing one of the
built-in ones there
then you can see that card title it's
slightly bigger it's it's a h5 tag there
so we've got text lg large text
font semi-bold okay so we've got heavier
font weight and mb2 margin bottom two
and then that paragraph text is just
sort of regular text so that's just
using the base sizing so that's text
based
so hopefully you can see already that
tailwind when you're using towel in css
classes it's quite easy to understand
once you've learned the the shortened
names that tailwind has
exactly what styles are being applied to
what html elements and you're not having
to flip back and forth between two files
to check this stuff out
so this can really add uh some uh
efficiency benefits
now as i mentioned tailwind comes with a
design system and it's completely
configurable it's very easy to configure
okay we configure this using a
javascript object
it's got a built-in sizing scale and
this applies to all kinds of things
related to start relate to size so
things like
padding and margins and things like this
they all use this sizing scale
by default it ships with a proportionate
scale so this makes life quite easy as
the developer to kind of figure out
sizing because say you start off with a
size of four but you want something a
lot bigger where you go to eight and
eight is double the size of four okay it
sort of makes sense when you're using it
but this is all configurable and you can
change this and if you say are working
somewhere with a design team you can
work with the designers to actually
configure tailwind to match your design
system okay so that's and that's like i
said quite an easy thing to do
as i said it's got a color palette built
into it and this is what that color
palette i've got the example here with
purple it ranges from
50 up to 900 with 900 being the darker
shade 50 being the lightest
and tailwind also has this concept of
variants which essentially marked to
match to pseudo
classes in css okay so things like hover
effects or odd even row effects or
responsive um sort of
break points and things like that they
all map to variance in tailwind okay
so really what you can think of with
towerwind is it's essentially like lego
blocks that's the way i look at it okay
we just put the various blocks together
to compose the look and feel that we
want
and if we don't like it any point we
just discard a block and change it for
something different if you think about
that card component i showed you if i
want that that uh card title bit that h5
that was in there to be a different
color i just swap text gray 800 for text
blue
and very quickly i've changed the text
color okay i don't have to go into a css
file find the right class find the right
property add in the hex code and what
have you
so
at this point
people who are relatively new to
tailwind start to get concerned
chris
isn't this inline styles
and as you're as old enough as i am to
remember when these were used a lot
inline styles are known to be evil
and we shouldn't be using them and this
is a fair question i think at this point
so let's just quickly address the
limitations of inline styles
so inline styles are essentially magic
numbers or magic strings however you
want to look at it
what this means is if i've got an h1 tag
on a page and i want to add a certain
set of styles to it to make it big and
bold and whatever whatever
i can do that with inline styles on that
one page on that one element
if i want it on another page on another
h1 tag i have to essentially copy and
paste that same set of inline styles and
i do that again and again for every page
on my site
the problem is if i want to change this
i've now got an issue because i've now
got to go back through every single page
i have and manually change all of these
inline styles okay so that's not great
the other issue with
or another issue i should say with
inline styles is that we can't do any of
the more interesting things like hover
effects okay so if i want a nice effect
when i mouse over a link
i can't do that with inline styles
they're just not physically support they
just can't physically support that
and finally if you have any interest in
responsive design then with inline
styles you are well out of luck because
they don't support that either okay so
we can build our websites
but we can't take any advantage of that
and make it look good on mobile and
tablet uh and and desktop so these are
some pretty significant limitations that
you have with inline styles
but none of this is the case for
tailwind because tailwind is still using
css classes okay so we've got all the
benefits of css classes and what they
can do
but like i said they're just very very
focused
pretty much always on a single css
property
so that's a bit about uh tower wind
let's start talking a bit about how we
can bring tower wind and blazer together
and how we would actually
add tailwind into a blazer project
so there's a couple of options here um
i'm going to talk about um the first one
we'll just skip through relatively
quickly and this is using tailwind virus
cdn so tailwind offers a pre-built
version
of its of its library
through their cdm you can just add a
link to it like this in your head tag
and you're off to the races you can just
start putting in those utility classes
and starting your site
however this is
relatively limited
um we can't customize anything as i
mentioned uh talwin has this kind of
rich design system that you can
configure really easily but because this
is a pre-built file on a cdm we can't
actually manipulate that
now i will caveat this by saying that
this is true of tailwind and version v2
okay tailwind v3 you are actually gonna
be able to customize this doing some
really interesting stuff um again it
wouldn't be something you want to use in
production but at development time you
can you could configure this um from the
cdn but it's not something that's
possible right now
tailwind comes as well with the set of
sensible defaults okay
if all of the various defaults of taowin
were turned on by
were turned on
from the get-go
uh it generates like a 20 meg plus css
file okay which is pretty massive to the
point where if you load that into a
browser it slows it down devtools gets
slow it's not that great so a lot of
things are turned off by default
sensible defaults okay
and this means that we can't turn them
on again from the cdm because we don't
have access to that configuration file
we also can't use third-party plug-ins
okay tailwind has a plug-in model and
there's plenty of plug-ins available for
it um third party and first party
plugins in fact but again we can't
access the configuration file so we
can't use them
and also we can't remove any unused
styles
so one of the uh
another good feature of talwind is the
fact that has this ability to uh purge
all of the unused css from its uh final
css file okay and it does this by
looking at all of the files that you use
tailwind classes in and then only
including those classes in the final
outputted file this means that tailwind
css files are usually very very small in
the region of 10k
the cdn version isn't huge it's like i
think 70 to 80k i think last time i
checked okay so it's not ginormously
massive but that is like seven or eight
times bigger than you get it if you
built it locally um so compared to that
it is a bit bigger
so
the other option and the one that we're
going to use throughout our demos today
is the tailwind cli
so
um one of the advantages of using the
tauwin cli and the way i'm going to show
you today is that you don't actually
have to
go through the process of creating
things like package.json files this
isn't going to create a big node modules
folder locally either or anything like
that
all we're going to need is node
installed the machine okay so we can get
access to a command called mpx
with tailwind cli we also get access to
like the watch mode that it has and this
does some hot reload so this will watch
the files that we're using um and it
will automatically rebuild our final css
file if it needs to if anything changes
for whatever reason
the tailwind cli also has optimizations
for tailwind's jit compiler now this is
in preview mode in v2 we're going to be
using this today but it will be the
default in v3 which is probably going to
be released in a few in the next sort of
month or two potentially so it's
definitely worth understanding this
and also with the tao and cli we can
also use other post css plugins um
tailwind itself is a post css plugin and
if you're not aware of what post css is
because i appreciate you might not be
it's a tool for transforming css into an
abstract syntax tree
and that means you can then walk that
tree you can manipulate it you can do
whatever you want to do reorder things
create new uh branch whatever and then
you can just write that back to a css
string when you're done and tailwind
uses this extensively to create utility
classes
so
i think that's enough powerpoint
let's jump over to visual studio and
let's start looking at what this looks
like in action so
let me pop over to visual studio here um
i have got a blazer webassembly
application here although it's not quite
the default okay um i think if anyone's
been looking at blazer stuff you're
probably
getting bored of that default template
with the purple gradient down the side
which was it's been lovely but it's
around been around for quite a while
so what i've done is i've i've done a
bit of work here to redesign this a bit
i've stripped out all the default
bootstrap stuff that comes with this
template
and i've replaced it with tailwind
utility classes but most importantly i
haven't actually integrated tailwind
into this okay because we'll do this
together so we can see what this looks
like
so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
start off by adding a new folder here so
i'm going to say ads i'm going to say
new folder
i'm going to call this one styles and
then we're going to add a style sheet
into that so let's go there
and where are we
stylesheet and this will be called app
css cool
so inside of there i'm going to paste in
these three lines of code
so these are tailwind directives
and these three lines of code
three lines of code are going to grow a
lot all right when we actually pass this
through tauwin cli but we'll have a look
at that in a second so that's the first
thing that we need to do the other thing
that we need to do is to create a
tailwind configuration file so again i'm
going to add a new item here this is
going to be javascript file
and we're going to call it
tailwind.config.js
there we go
and this is basically just a minimum
configuration file for towerwind right
i'm not customizing anything i'm not
going to try and do anything fancy like
that here um this is just the basically
going to use the the defaults for
tailwind i'm not really going to go a
lot into customizing this to be honest
the docks cover that really well so i
don't think i can really add a huge
amount there
but this is what we're going to need to
get started
cool so we've got that
i'm now going to jump over to my command
line and i'm going to run this command
mpx tailwind css and then i'm going to
pass in
that uh app css that we just created
okay that's gonna be our input or our
source css file
and then i'm gonna say
output the final result of passing that
file into the wwe root folder css folder
into an app css file so we're going to
run that
and off this is going to go
it's going to npx is sort of a bit
different to npm in that this isn't
actually going to install anything
locally it just sort of caches what it
needs executes the command and then
tidies up after itself which is quite
nice so you can see here uh it's been
done just shy of five seconds to compile
our css so let's go and have a look what
we've got from that
so if we go in the uh
www root folder here we go we've got our
final css file so
whoo
there is some css in here isn't there uh
what have we got and i still need the
bottom
we've got 188 380 lines of css that's
quite a lot of css isn't it
um and all that came from those three
little lines that we put in okay and
this is what tailwind's done through
post css it's uh sort of expanded those
three lines out into all these based on
the settings in tailwind's configuration
file
if we go and have a look what this looks
like on disk
uh
yeah that's also a pretty hefty css file
we've got there
about
about four meg just show a full meg um
yeah that's that's quite large um
so this is one way that we could do it
all right
um but like i said tailwind shipping
with this new jit compiler
and the jit compiler is a bit different
instead of kind of creating all of these
classes up front and then we might only
use a subset of them
with the jit compiler it can just
monitor our files and only uh sort of uh
use or put in the file in the css
classes that we're actually using in our
app and it will do this on the fly for
us so we never end up with this huge
file we end up with something much much
smaller so how do we configure the jit
compiler
so let's just update
the
the towering configuration file here so
first of all i'm going to tell talent
that i want it to use the jit mode okay
by saying mode is jit
and then when i'm using jit mode i have
to specify the files where tailwind can
find my usage of these utility classes
so i've got
basically pointing it there the
index.html which is the host page for
this blazer app and then i'm also saying
any file that ends in dot razer okay go
and look in there that's where you'll
find all of the utility classes so we've
done that
let's go back to our command lines
so i'm going to run that same command as
i did before but this time as well i'm
going to put in
this other switch minus minus watch and
this is just going to put tail the towel
and climb watch mode so every time we
make a change it's going to rebuild that
final css file for us
so let's let that run
wow that was a lot quicker wasn't it
it built the css this time in 102
milliseconds
much much quicker so let's have a look
what we've got now
uh so this is the output css file and
we're now at 964 lines this feels a
little bit more reasonable doesn't it um
and if we have a look on disk yeah okay
this is this is looking this is looking
a lot better we're at 16k now okay
because what it's done is it scanned all
the files in my application it's only
put the ones i'm using into this into
this final css file and this means that
really when i'm sort of doing my
development work like this i'm also
working with a file much closer to what
it would be in the production system and
i think it's always a good idea to work
as close to production on your
development machine as you as you can
really
cool
so let's actually run this up and see
what this looks like so before i do that
i just need to add a link into the host
page here for that css file i've created
and then
let's spin this up and actually see what
this looks like and you can all judge my
uh very uh
not great design skills
there we go
so
i'll just give that a little zoom
so this is kind of my reimagining of the
of the the default blazer template okay
so like i said i've already put a load
of tailwind styles in order to do this
because watching me type loads of
utility classes is not overly exciting
but what i thought i would do so you can
get a bit of a feel what it's like to
actually uh sort of start work with
tailwind um
is to show you a couple of things i
always find quite tricky to do with css
um they're always things i end up having
to google i can never quite remember the
syntax and and all that one of them is a
a gradient background that's always a
bit of a tricky one and the other one is
sort of applying sort of 2d 3d effects
to elements all right so
that panel on the right hand side there
all right that that would be really good
if we have a nice bold gradient
background on it okay just to make it
pop off the page a bit so how do we do
that with with tailwind
well what i'm going to do is i'm going
to open up
the index page this chunk of markup here
is is what that panel is
so on the outer one i'm just going to
pop in three utility classes okay so
it's these three classes here
so bg gradient 2br so this is going to
say a background gradient from top right
um top left to bottom right
and i'm going to say i want it to go
from green 400 to blue 500 that's it so
if i save that
and i've got a gradient
three quick utility classes and i've got
this gradient by now i'd still be on
stack overflow probably trying to copy
and paste from someone or other um so
this is i think one of the key things
for tailwind for me these more what i
thought certainly for me what are
slightly trickier things to do uh become
very very quick and easy um and like i
said we can always customize this
however we want so i can now say i want
purple 500 instead okay and i can jump
back and it's got a slight purple hue
down there now right so it's easy to
make these changes
the other thing is like i said sort of
2d 3d effects so um this survey prompt
over here is looking a little sorry for
itself so let's see if we can uh sort of
spruce that up a little bit
so in this
shared folder this is the current markup
for that so i'm just going to
add some styles in and let's go look
what that looks like so that looks a
little bit nicer already but everything
on this page is very square isn't it
it's very well lined up i want that uh
survey prompt to be a little bit more
like a banner so i want to skew it about
i want to twist it around i'm just going
to sort of rotate it slightly and just
sort of make things look a little bit
like say less square so i can do that
pretty simply as well with tailwind i
can just go on to again the out div here
and again i'll just pop in two classes
so i'm going to say i want to transform
this element by using the transform
class and then i'm going to say i just
want to rotate it by three and again
three will map to an amount in that
design system
but rotate on its own would make it go
clockwise okay and i don't want that i
want to go the other way so i can just
stick a minus in front of it okay and it
will go counterclockwise
so let's save that we go over there and
you can see it just
quickly flicks around
pretty quick and easy compared to
writing this by hand okay and i'm
someone who actually weirdly likes css
um but i can't write it this quickly
okay so um that's just a little flavor
of sort of what it's like to sort of
apply these utility classes okay
cool so
i'm going to address something at this
point which again is usually something
that comes up quite quickly with
tailwind is
what about reuse styles
it's great having all these nice focused
classes but what happens if i want to
use them over and over again this is a
problem that inline styles has isn't it
that i then have to go back and i have
to change them everywhere
fair question fair point
so i've got a couple of uh scenarios
here for us to look at that cover that
first of all uh if we look at this app
this panel
is everywhere it's on all of the pages
okay that's the same markup repeated
over and over again so that's not great
so we should definitely refactor that
and the other thing is all of these h1
and p tags okay here and here they're
the same on every page okay and they're
reusing the same styles so
that's another example okay so let's
have a look at two ways we can tackle
this
so the first one is to use components
all right we're using blazer here it's a
ui based uh
framework so we can just create a
component and put all of that uh
repeated code in there so let's have a
look at doing that so
this shared folder i'm going to add in a
new component i'm going to call this
tailwind
panel
okay
and then with that
i can just put in that markup that's
been repeated across all those different
pages so i'll save that
dot next hot reload says that's a bit
too much for me i'm going to need to do
a rebuild so we'll let that
do its thing
and then what i can do is on each page i
can now just come in here and i can just
take that markup and i can just go right
i want to use the tailwind panel instead
so i'll take that we'll go over to the
counter page and we can replace it on
there as well
and we'll do the same thing on the fetch
data page and we'll get rid of that okay
so if we save that and we go back to our
app
everything is still exactly the same
which it should be except now all of
that repeated code is in a single
component okay so i can come back over
here i can go in my panel and i can say
right we said we had purple before
didn't we so we'll go back to a purple
gradient and now you can see i've got a
purple gradient and it's on every page
all right so that's one way i can deal
with repeated markup and repeated styles
and things like that
this other way though is something that
is tailwind specific and
funnily enough a lot of people i've seen
who use tailwind aren't aware that you
can do this and i think this is an
incredibly cool feature so
um i like to use this feature mainly
when i'm gonna have repeated styles on
on sort of uh regular html elements like
h1 tags or p tags or anchor tags as well
as another great example um
so i'm going to open up that source css
file that we have okay and i'm going to
add some
some styles into this
so i've got two classes here to find for
an h1 and a p tag
and then what i'm using is tailwind's
apply directive and then i'm just
writing out utility classes again all
right so as i promised you at the start
of this talk i would not be writing a
css property and i've kept my word i
have not written a css property all
right i've defined a class so i've
walked the line there but i haven't
actually run a property
this is a very powerful feature i think
that towerwind has and sometimes i don't
think everyone is aware of it because
this is still going to use all of our
design system configuration we've done
and everything like that um but i don't
still have don't actually have to write
any css properties so
we're going to save that and then what
we'll do is go on to each of these pages
and we can get rid of all of these
repeated
class declarations here so we'll get rid
of it off
the index page we'll get rid of it off
uh the counter page there
we don't need those
and where's our other one fetch data all
right we'll get rid of it off here as
well just for good measure so we're
being responsible developers and not
having any repeated code anywhere there
we go so let's save that if we go back
over to our app well everything's still
looking exactly the same as it was well
it should do
but if we go and actually have a look at
the source code now you can see down
here
there's no class on that h1 there's no
class on that p tag um you can see over
here it's actually coming from the app
css file
so
what happens is sort of similar to the
other bits of tailwind once that goes
through tailwind cli
if we go and have a look at the
outputted css file
you can see
that is what we defined in the source
file and it's now been transformed into
css properties by the towel in cli and
we've not had to do any of that heavy
lifting which is which is lovely and i'm
a big fan of this so um this is a really
powerful technique okay and um like i
say saves you having or not having to
repeat lots and lots of styles and get
you away from that inline styles issue
okay
lovely
so
let me just grab the water
um
so this has been this has been all right
so far but let's uh start talking about
a few more interesting things let's talk
about animations
now animations especially with blazer i
get i see a lot of people asking about
this i've had a lot of questions about
how to do this
and generally they can be a bit tricky
usually involve having to do some
javascript and things like that
but i'm going to show you a technique
with blazer today and using tailwind i'm
not going to use any javascript at all
we're going to do this just with
c sharp code and tailwind
utility classes so i thought what would
uh really make this page pop a little
bit is if that panel slid in okay that
would be really cool wouldn't it that
would definitely make this look fast
nastier so when this first loads it will
slide in from the right hand side and
it'll fade in as well and it'll just
give the page a little bit of extra
punch so how do we do that
well we're going to start off by
creating a component let's do that
and this is going to be called
slide in
because that's what's going to happen
and then what i want to do is add in
some initial code for this
so this is going to be
basically a component that wraps other
markup and is going to animate that
markup so we need to capture any code
between the start and end tags of this
particular component and we need to put
it somewhere okay so that we can animate
it so we're going to do that by defining
a parameter and that's going to have a
type of render fragment and then we're
using the special convention in blazer
where we call it child content and that
basically means anything between the
start and end tags of this component
capture into this property
we can then push that we can now put the
the value in that property wherever we
want and the markup contained there okay
and we're doing that up here okay using
this razor syntax and that's inside of
this div and this div is the thing we're
gonna animate and then because
everything else is in it that's gonna be
animated as well
so
we're gonna add some initial uh styles
in here so
the key ones are the three in the middle
uh transition duration 500 okay that
means that any css property value we
change we want to change over a period
of time and that duration is 500
milliseconds
and then we've got transformers well on
there so we used this earlier to rotate
that element okay and we're going to use
it to actually move this element on the
x-axis okay so horizontally and we're
going to push it off the side of the
page initially and that's why that's on
there
we've also got another bit of uh
blazer code razor code in here okay
we're outputting the value of this
animation styles field okay and we're
gonna actually use that to dynamically
change the style so we do need some
default styles in here
so let's pop them in next
so we're going to say
here that initially when this component
renders
we're going to translate it x or we're
going to apply the class translate x
full what this means is move uh that
particular element 100 of its width to
the right and this is going to push it
off the page because it's on the right
hand side
and we're also saying initially um set
the opacity to zero by adding the
opacity zero class
so that's what's going to happen when we
first load the page it's going to be off
to the side and invisible
so let's uh let's go a bit further into
this so uh we've got a timer in here
okay so this timer is going to have a
duration of 300 milliseconds
and it's not going to repeat i've got
auto reset to false we don't want this
kind of coming in and out constantly
that would be really annoying so we
don't want that happening but when it
does elapse we want to call this
handler trigger animation so let's add
that in
so trigger animation's job is purely to
update that animation um animation
styles field with new uh tailwind
classes but they're you they're um
adjusting the same css properties so
we're still doing translate x except
this time it's zero and this means that
we're bringing it back to where it
should be rendered on the page okay
we've pushed it off originally now we're
letting it come back to where it was
and we're saying opacity 100 and making
it fully visible
and this is where it ties in with that
transition and that duration 500. all
right because we're manipulating the
same css properties they're going to
happen over that manipulation is going
to happen over a period of 500
milliseconds and that's what's going to
create the animation effect all right
so the only thing that's left for us to
do here is to actually trigger that
timer and we're going to do that
using the on after render lifecycle
method
so we're going to say on the first
render if this is the first render of
this component start the timer
okay and then after 300 milliseconds
it's going to slide in and
hopefully everything will work
so that's it for
our component so we can just go and uh
use this now so if we go back to our
home page
and we're just gonna wrap
our tailwind panel in that component
like so
if i save that
go back
and i've now got a sliding component
okay
so that's that's quite cool if i go to a
different page come back again it slides
in
so not bad
it's not quite perfect yet though
because you may notice
the eagle mid if you look at the bottom
of the screen there there is a short
period there where we've got a
horizontal scroll bar okay and that's
because we've pushed out of the viewport
to the right and the browser's very
helpfully gone oh that's off the
viewport you want a scroll bar so you
can get to it obviously we're just
trying to hide it so we can fix that
quite quickly as well we can go into the
host page here
and on the body tag
we'll just say
overflow
hidden
cool and that never picks that up so
i'll do a reload
there we go
so now
we're not seeing that
horizontal scroll bar anymore we've just
got a nice smooth animation with that
fading in okay we don't have to use any
javascript to do that that's just using
blazer and tailwind
cool
so
that's that bit
the other thing that i want to talk
about as well is dark mode this is
something i'm quite passionate about you
can probably see this from the ui i do
like dark mode i've got dark mode on my
phone i've got it on my visual studio i
even got dark mode slides okay
so i think it'd be really good if this
template had some form of dart mode in
it
so tailwind actually has a dart mode
option available to us so we can turn
that on and use that so let's go and
look at how we can do that so if we go
in our tailwind configuration file we
can actually enable this we can say dark
mode
and by default
if you don't declare it whether it's
just this dark mode false
but we've got another option we can say
dark mode media
so we can save that
go back over to our site and oh we've
suddenly got our almost dark mode
now i just want to be clear this is not
telling being ultra clever and somehow
working out how to do dart mode for me i
have cheated a little bit and i've
already applied some style classes
specifically for dart mode again just so
you don't have to watch me do that over
and over again but i have left that
title bar at the top there i've left
that installed at the moment just so you
can see what what that looks like to
apply those styles so let's go and do
that now
so i'm just going to change up this
initial markup on the nav menu
there we go
so
the way that we apply dark mode styles
in tailwind is using a variant this
variant is called dark so what we do is
we say
by default here we're having the
background is white by adding the bg
white class
but we're going to say if dark mode is
activated
apply bg gray 700
and this is how you add styling for dark
mode in tallwood in tailwind you just
basically add dark in front of the
classes that you only want to apply
during dark mode and everything else
will only get applied during light mode
okay
um so that's that's quite cool so let's
save that if we go back over there we go
that's reloaded and now we've got our
dark mode on our header as well so our
site is now entirely in dark mode which
is which is great
now when we're using the media option um
this is being inferred based on my
browser settings or my operating system
settings so if i go in my browser
settings here go to appearance
i think you go there and i switch to
light mode it just automatically goes
straight back to light mode
if i go dark mode it goes to dark mode
and because my system preference is dark
mode i go to system default and it's
still dark mode
so that's what the media option does so
when dart mode is media it's just going
to infer it
however um
i think it's always good to give people
options i mean even myself as a big fan
of dark mode there's days where i do
like do like light mode i like to burn
my retinas every now and then
so i think it'd be much better to have
kind of some kind of toggle here so we
could switch between the modes and let
the user choose whatever they wanted so
let's go and have a look at how we can
implement some kind of component to do
that
so let's start off by creating a
component for this in the shared folder
so i'm going to add a new component here
i'm going to call it dark mode toggle
and then i'm going to pop in some
code here in fact i'm not going to do
that bit so we'll get rid of that
so this initial code is basically just
going to render a nice toggle switch for
us um so that's what all of this markup
is doing
i'm using a little trick here that's
kind of quite common in the front end
world where
i've got a label uh with a div in it and
i've styled that to look like a little
round disc that's going to slide back
and forth there's a slider and then i've
got that attached to a hidden input
field that's the thing that's actually
going to receive the button click and
check back and forth
um
i'm binding to that so i've got a field
here
defining my code block and i'm binding
to the checked value on that input here
and i'm also subscribing to the on
change event of this input and i'm
saying whenever that the value of this
input changes call my toggle theme event
handler okay and then that's got to do
in it because we need to implement some
code here
so
before we go any further let's actually
have a look what this looks like so
we'll let that build and we'll just add
that into our header here so we'll say
dark mode toggle like so
save that
come back over and this is what our
toggle looks like okay so when we're in
dark mode it's gonna be highlighted on
the dark side and then we'll click on it
and it will slide over and go over to
the light side however right now it's
not doing a lot because we've obviously
got a bit more code that we need to
implement so let's uh have a look at
that
cool so the first thing i'm going to do
is i'm going to add another new item
here
and i'm going to add a little javascript
file all right actually before i go and
do that i'm going to show you something
else first
uh
actually i'm not i'm going to update
this config file um so
i almost forgot to do this so in well as
i said we've already set dart mode to
media and that means that it's inferred
by default but if we want to control
that we actually have to change the
setting okay so we have to change it to
a different setting called class
when we change it to class that means
that tailwind is going to look for a
class called dark somewhere in the dom
tree and it's basically any uh children
elements are then going to have their
dark variants applied so
let me quickly show you what this looks
like
uh if i open up the browser tools here
and if we go to this html element at the
top and say dark and add that
now it goes into dark mode okay
so that's where that class needs to be
for us and when we remove that class it
goes back to light mode so this is what
our component's going to need to do
and this is something that we are going
to need to use a bit of javascript for
okay because we can't actually get to
that tag in blazer directly
so
let's go and add that javascript file
now
and there we go and i'm going to call it
dark
mode toggle
dot razer dot js
so that's going to nest it there under
the component that's going to use it
this is using a new feature that's part
of net 6
and this is called co-located javascript
okay
historically with blazer we always had
to keep our static assets up here in
this wwe root folder
this could be a bit of a pain for
productivity because you're having to
jump around you're never quite sure what
file necessarily related to a particular
component that was using it
but with this we can actually put the
javascript side by side with the
component that's using it which is quite
nice
in terms of the actual javascript we use
it's pretty simplistic okay so i'm
defining a javascript module here i've
got a function and i'm exporting that
function that function is called set
theme and it takes a string which is the
actual theme
if that theme is dark then i'm going to
apply that dart class to that root html
element
if the theme is light then i'm going to
remove that dark element so it's a
fairly simplistic
script
so we can save that
and we don't need to worry about that
anymore that's all dealt with
what we do need to do though is be able
to call that from our blazer component
so
let's add a bit of code in to enable us
to do that
uh where am i we want to import
that module so uh blazer i think it was
in dot net 5 um brought in this concept
of importing javascript modules so this
is quite a nice feature because it means
that if you uh never hit a component in
a blazer app that uses that bit of
javascript it will never actually get
downloaded to the client so that can
save you a bit of a bit of size
potentially
to capture and a reference to a
javascript module we use the i
igs object reference type okay so i've
got a field here
that's defined using that type and then
in the on after render lifecycle method
i'm calling into the javascript
apis that blazer exposes okay and i'm
injecting that at the top here the igs
runtime
and then i'm saying my return type is
going to be an igs object reference and
then i'm using the import keyword this
is a special keyword in this in this um
when we're using javascript modules
and then the second argument there is
actually the route to that particular
javascript module okay so i've now got
that captured over here in this theme
module field
um so now we've got that we can update
this toggle method okay with some actual
code so
let's add this in
so remember this is going to get called
every single time
that that
input
check value changes
so we're going to
capture whatever the current value of
that is in that dart mode field so if
it's true then we're dark mode is true
otherwise it's false
we say if if dartmouth is true
then call into our module call our set
theme function and pass in dark as the
theme otherwise pass in light okay so
that's what that's doing
so if i save that and if we go back over
to our
application
hopefully now
we've got a working
toggle between light and dark mode
and if you look as well that that you're
getting a little animation there where
that slides back and forth between the
two
let's just quickly have a look at that
as well up here in the markup this is
using a similar technique to what we
used before so this div is that what
that little disc is
and that's got that transform class on
it duration of 300
and then the key part is we're saying
when we're in dark mode translate x3 so
push it slightly to by three to the
right and that's why it slides over to
the dark side
no pun intended yet
or it goes back to the light side when
we come out of dark mode so that's how
we're getting that little animation
happening there
so
yeah this is pretty cool we've already
you know we've got dart mode now we can
toggle between light and dark mode which
is great the only problem we've got now
is that basically when i come in here
and i refresh my application so i've
gone away and i come back again we're
back in light mode
which is a bit frustrating you know
there's a lot of work going up there and
clicking that button every time i visit
the site i don't want to have to do that
so it would be nice if we could persist
this choice for the user so they don't
have to
have to do that every time so let's have
a look at doing that
so
i'm gonna do at this point a shameless
plug for one of my open source libraries
which is called blazer local storage i'm
quite proud of it's the first
open source library i ever created and
it's just uh as of a few weeks ago went
past a million downloads so i'm feeling
pretty pretty proud about that and big
thank you to everybody who's ever used
it or contributed so so yeah
but what it's for is for interrupting
with the browser's local storage apis
but using c sharp code okay so what we
can do is we can inject this ilocal
storage service into any component and
then we can access local storage in
whatever way we see fit so in this case
we're going to update
this if statement so every time we set
the theme we're also going to persist
that choice into local storage for the
user so let's add that in
so that's what this looks like on the
local storage service and we've got
access to various different methods in
this case we're calling the set item as
string the first argument there is the
key in local storage we're going to call
that theme and then the second argument
is the value which in this case is going
to be dark okay and that's if we're in
dark mode if the user is choosing light
mode then obviously we're going to set
the value of the theme key to light
instead so
we've done that let's let that rebuild
and we'll go over to our app so this is
looking uh pretty much the same as it
did before i can toggle it to dark mode
same as i did before which is good and
hopefully now if i reload it's not
worked
so that's annoying why has that not
worked well it's because we've kind of
done it half and half if we go in here
we can actually see in the local storage
we've actually done the initial piece of
work we've got that theme key in there
and we've got the value set as dark
which is great um the only problem is we
haven't actually read it out when we
first loaded up the component okay so
when the app reloads it's it's still not
being able to get that so we need to
read that value out
so we'll do that in this on after render
method we can do it after we load this
theme module so let's let's add the code
in for that
so i'll put space there so we've added
these three lines in
rebuilding the background
so what i'm saying is on the first
render and this will only execute once
in the life cycle of this particular
lifetime of this component um
we're going to say go into local storage
and get this particular key okay that's
what we're saying the key is called
theme and get its value
and then what we're going to say is if
the theme is is equal to dark then dark
mode is true otherwise dark mode is
false and then regardless of whatever
one we're picking we're then going to
call into our javascript module i'm
going to call that set theme function to
set the theme to whatever the user's
choice was
so if we go back over to our app this
time
and you can see i can still toggle but
if all goes well we refresh and now it's
remembered our choice and we've got uh
we've got our dark mode remembered okay
so um so yeah so that's cool so we've
now got a nice dark mode system set up
the user can toggle between whichever
one they choose
and it's also going to remember their
settings between visits which is which
is great
so
the last thing i want to talk to you
about and round this off with is about
how we can then move into production
with this okay because everything i've
been showing you so far has been
obviously local development i've been
using my cli commands locally in my
terminal and things like that so how we
actually put this into like a ci
pipeline or something like that well
you've got a couple of options there i
mean obviously this is a an m this mpx
command can be run uh in a cli uh
in a cd pipeline
cicd pipeline um by putting some form of
task in there that can execute um
cli commands so you could do it that way
but there's another option as well you
can use and that's actually integrating
this a bit with ms build so to do that
if we open up the cs proj file here
i can add in a couple of targets all
right
now
this first target here this check for
npm
this is set to run uh this is basically
essentially the first thing that's going
to run whenever i trigger a build and
it's actually going to do exactly what
it says on the tin it's going to check
that npm is available okay and that
basically means that we've got node
available which is what we need in order
to execute that mpx command so that's
just going to ask that's going to
execute npm space minus v and that
should print out the node the npm
version okay
if that doesn't happen there'll be an
error and that will foul the build so
that's just a bit of safety checking for
us
the next target
is um the one that's going to do all of
the heavy lifting so first of all um i'm
going to set an environment variable
like i said the node environment no end
variable to production this is something
that tailwind needs to know that we're
going to do a production build and this
is going to add some optimizations for
us
then the command i want to run is going
to be the same one that we were running
from our terminal okay when we first
started this mpx tailwind
telling css the input file the output
file
but because this is a production build
i'm also going to pass in this other
flag minus minus minify
so under the hood what this is actually
going to use is another post css plugin
called nano css okay and this is a
pretty popular plugin for dealing with
css
and it's just going to minify it all for
us and make even smaller than it was
before
and then just for good measure because i
don't want this happening at development
time or anything like that i only want
this to happen in production um is i'm
going to put a condition on this
particular command and i'm going to say
only execute this when we're doing a
release build so at the moment we're in
debug mode so this will only execute
when we're doing a release build
okay
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to go over to my
terminal over here so you can see
from this this is the tailwind cli
that's been running it's been doing lots
and lots of
builds in the background as we've been
adding in new css classes and all this
stuff so we're going to cancel that now
we don't need this anymore
and
i think
we were at 16k i think i believe our
tower when css file was initially before
we started all of this so what we're
going to do now is swap over to release
mode
and then i'm just going to
build uh this this solution again
so if we come down here into the
console output you can see
what's been going on so first of all
we've got that and the result of that
npm minus v command okay so that's
printing out that version number which
is great and then the next thing is we
can see that mpx command
and the build of the css that's been
happening all right so those those two
targets have been running so let's have
a look what it's done for it so we open
up
the app css file okay straight away we
can see it's been minified everything's
all on one line now so that's quite good
if we scroll across we can see that all
of the white space is gone which is is
good that's what we expect when we
minify things if i go back over to the
file system though and have a look here
we can see
that our final output css
is now smaller yet again we're down to
10k which i think is something i said
right near the start is about what you
can get from a tailwind css build in
production this is pretty tiny css file
okay
so this is uh looking pretty good i
think we've done some pretty good work
here today and hopefully this has been
uh sort of interesting
and entertaining um if i just jump back
over to my slides here
okay and then go on to this last one
i just want to say thank you very much
for coming and watching
all of the demo code and the slides are
available at that url that's in the
middle there
and um of course if you would like to
buy a copy of my book for any reason you
know i'm not pushing you to but you know
you all look like wonderful people who
would like to do that of course
you can get 35 off of that discount code
that's down in the bottom corner there
and that's it i hope you've enjoyed it
um there's
things at the side to rate this on your
way out and it would be very much
appreciated if you could but otherwise
thank you very much for coming and enjoy
the rest of the afternoon
you